great okay so uh we have limited time
I have some notebooks and I have some
slides it's the end of the day so I
figure you're probably exhausted you
don't really want to like think through
like how do I code this up in a notebook
so unless there are any objections I
might just scroll through the notebook
and sort of tell you what's going on
your brains are all fried I'm sure mine
is too
okay great uh so yeah intro to causal
inference
causal inference is a really
um it's a very like Theory heavy and
math heavy and like philosophical topics
so I'm going to try to make it as
practical and down to earth as possible
so you can leave here and immediately
learn more if you want or leave here and
say this really isn't for me so I'm
gonna go learn something else that's
cool too
um so I'm hoping by the end of the
session you'll have a good sense for
like what are the problems with
analyzing observational data
because there are many
um understanding the various types of
causal relationships you could have in
nature
understanding how statistical analysis
causal inference and experimentation or
a B testing relate to each other and
their various strengths and then
hopefully you'll have that foundational
knowledge to kind of go forth and do
something yourself I think you can after
this
um but to begin with I think this is a
useful frame for thinking about causal
and Friends way back in the day uh back
in the day being 2020.
um there was some suggestion that
vitamin D was associated with
um severity of covid symptoms people
thought if you really Mega dose stuff on
vitamin D you might have less severe
symptoms if you caught covid
we're not really sure but that was the
thing going around and if you think
about how in an ideal Universe where you
have all the power you need you know you
can sort of shape reality and stuff if
you wanted to understand if that was
true or not you would take someone
um you would sort of you know note their
daily habits what they do their you know
where they work what they eat you would
note that in 2020 early 2020 they start
mega dosing on vitamin D
um they live their life they you know
stay isolated they occasionally meet a
friend outside blah blah blah
um they get covered with mild symptoms
in mid-2020 okay you can't really tell
much from that though right it could be
a whole host of reasons why they only
got minor covid
um
what we could do if we had all this
power in the universe is
um examine something called a
counterfactual scenario the word
counterfactual comes from like
philosophy and history it's a term those
that's used in those disciplines it just
means what we don't observe in reality
it's counter to fact
um an endless alternative reality you
could create
exactly the same person who never takes
vitamin D but we hold constant every
other aspect of their being who they are
friends with what they eat where they
work etc
and we followed them forward and we
could see what happens and then you
would have a real understanding of you
know for this individual at least what
is the effect of vitamin D
supplementation now obviously we can't
do that that's like black magic but what
we can do is and our best attempt at
this is rolling out a b tests or
randomized control trials or whatever
you want to call it experiments where we
take a group of treated individuals and
a group of control individuals and we
sort of roll forward in time and see
what happens in one group we have some
sort of intervention maybe the treatment
group takes high dose vitamin D the
other one doesn't they take a sugar pill
or something some Placebo and then we
see what happens at the end of the day
the problem is experiments aren't always
going to be there for us experiments are
costly they take infrastructure if
you're in the tech World
sometimes they're not ethical so I'm an
epidemiologist by training I used to
study lead exposure in children and I
can't dose pregnant at mothers with lead
that's highly ethical right sure I could
do something else interesting like maybe
I could roll out remediation efforts to
various households and see if that there
are like positive impacts to that and
sort of
backwards and fur that light is sort of
has an effect there but there are
problems with that too they're also just
not feasible you know if I want to
econometricians want to know if
household income levels and
neighborhoods are associated with
violent crime we can't randomly swap
homes and so we have like a very
homogeneous High income group in a mixed
income group and see how violence plays
out there are big problems with that
right so
um the whole point of this talk is to
introduce this category called causal
inference causal inference is sort of
this in between ground or that's how I'd
like to think of it between
um the highly idealized randomized
experiments on the right there which are
difficult to roll out sometimes but you
can make really strong causal claims in
them to on the other end of the spectrum
you know just getting a data set of
something you observed in real life and
running correlations on it like there
are problems with that we'll go through
that in a little bit so causal inference
is this nice sort of Middle Ground here
and a lot of organizations like my own
where we can't readily do experiments
because we work with a certain type of
patient data and it's just difficult to
do that we rely on causal reference
quite a bit and we try to beef up on
that skill set so
um that's what we're focusing on uh I
would recommend going forward you think
of causal and friends as sort of in the
same bucket as experimentation it's not
really
we use ML and causal inference but it's
not like another ml tool it's it's more
like along the lines of a b testing
essentially in that same bucket
um but to help spell that out even more
um here are a set of very typical causal
inference type questions research
questions
um and below that are typical ml
uh so questions like you know how does
improving neighborhood income inequality
reduce neighborhood crime rates or how
does increasing or decreasing the price
of a product impact demand
um in the causal inference bucket
all these questions involve some
intervention or some treatment or doing
some action right in the ml questions
there isn't that action necessarily it's
just you know how can I cluster stuff
um how can I predict whether this tweet
is a nice one or a bad one
um you know how can I predict whether
patients will get diabetes or not in the
future so with causal inference there's
always this notion of an action an
intervention a treatment a policy there
are tons of names for it but basically
it means you're doing something and we
want to see the impact of it
um
does that make sense because that's
that's kind of critical actually okay
cool
um can you raise your hands if you're
familiar with graphs because I can just
skip over this if everyone is oh well a
lot of people are okay
um
really quickly then I'll just speed
through this because there's a lot of
stuff here um
causal graphs are a way of representing
data and causal relationships between
them there's a lot of really complicated
causal inference uh approaches and sort
of theory around graphs we're not going
to do that at all because it's confusing
to people I find
so but just to kind of like Get get a
baseline Foundation out there
um you can think of a b c d and e as
representing variables or like
entities or concepts right and what the
arrows indicate is a causes e it's a
causal relationship
B causes e
C and D that double-headed Arrow there
can mean one of two things it can mean
it's sort of unspecified like we don't
know they're correlated or it could be
bi-directional causation like depression
and physical activity are
bi-directionally causal like if you're
depressed you're less likely to exercise
if you don't exercise you are more
likely to be depressed and sort of goes
back and forth
um and so that's that's essentially how
to interpret a causal graph it's a
really useful way of describing causal
relationships which we'll do in like two
minutes
um
usually this exercise is like it's a car
insurance one I do for folks that are
sort of newer to console graphs but I
think almost everyone raised their hands
so you get the idea
um so I'm going to Speed Ahead so taking
this idea of a causal graph we're going
to look at three critical types of
causal relationships in the world that
um you'll be considering all the time in
your work
um critical ones
so the first one and this will lead into
the first exercise by the way the first
one is something called a confounder
um but that's really annoying how it
formatted the T there like that
um
the way you can think of a confounder is
this um
so you have some treatment right some
action you want to take and you have
some outcome you know an analogous in
some ways to like an ml problem you have
predictors and you have
um the thing you're predicting
um so you have some action and you have
some outcome and you want to understand
this relationship
a confounder is a third variable that
causes both
doesn't seem like that big of a deal but
it actually is it's really important
um
it a confounder will essentially induce
bias in the relationship between your
treatment and your outcome and so if you
don't account for confounders and your
causal inference analysis your results
will be biased
um and so
very typical example here there's
actually a a really well known uh
commonly discussed correlation between
coffee and lung cancer and epidemiology
Community it doesn't actually exist
there's no causal relationship between
them but if you're given a data set of
like people's coffee consumption and
whether they got cancer down the road
you will oftentimes tend to see a strong
relationship it doesn't exist there's no
causal relationship there but smoking is
causally related to Coffee consumption
that's that's actually like a real
psychological fact related to dopamine
and smoking causes lung cancer and so
smoking acts as a confounder between
these two
and so anytime I want to understand the
relate the true causal relationship if
there is one between coffee and lung
cancer if I don't account for smoking
I'm going to be way off base it's going
to induce a spurious relationship
between coffee and lung cancer
this is called confounding it's a bad
thing you want to prevent it
confounding can do all sorts of
interesting awful things it can cause
positive associations it can cause
negative associations when they don't
exist
ideally in some model that you build you
want to control for it we'll get into
that a little later and a situation
where you don't fully control for
confounding results in something called
residual confounding like leftover
unattended to confounding which is not
great
um
yeah I can skip that uh so to make it
more real I think um let's say like
you're a mayor of a city with a lot of
violent crime
um and you have a team of analysts that
are running around the clock to like
figure out stuff for you answer
questions Etc
um and they come to you and they say we
have this huge data set of observational
data and we found a really significant
association between ice cream
consumption and violent crime and maybe
you should do something about this
um obviously like the naive approach
would here would be like well there's a
correlation so there must be a story
there right
um but there isn't one the truth is
there's confounding going on here by
warm weather in the summertime there
tends to be more violent crime because
there's more opportunity for it and ice
cream sales are higher in the summer
than they are in the winter
and so that's what's going on here it's
inducing this relationship by causing
both the treatment and the outcome and
so my treatment of my potential
treatment of uh tinkering with ice cream
sales isn't going to do anything in real
life because there's this confounding
going on
um if we somehow find a way to control
for this confounding variable you can
begin to understand the true
relationship if there is one at all
between ice cream and the outcome and
maybe if there is one then maybe ice
cream sales working on that as some sort
of treatment or policy would have some
good impact for you but I don't think it
would
um
so we're going to get into like how you
can control for things in quotes in a
little bit but um don't like let's not
get too ahead of ourselves
um we control for things in two ways uh
the first like simple naive way is to
Simply condition on something
um like stratify on it essentially so if
I have a data set of
um
you know I guess back in this case here
I'll go back to this
if I restrict my data set so I only have
observations in the summer time
this summer variable is no longer going
to exert an effect on this relationship
as there's no variability to it it
doesn't vary between one and zero one
two three four or whatever so if you
hold constant this confounder it's very
simple it's very naive it'll shrink your
sample size quite a bit but it will work
to control for things that's the simple
naive way
um two which we're going to go into a
little bit later is to use a model so
just keep that in mind
all right so we talked about confounders
right you always want to control
frequent Founders you want to identify
them using domain knowledge and
empirical data the next two
relationships are things you don't want
to touch like ever don't don't throw
them in the model don't control for them
just know what they are recognize them
in your data using domain knowledge and
then just sort of like leave them be
the first one is known as a collider so
again God I hate that uh but you have
this treatment causing an outcome
um
collider looks like a confounder but the
arrows are different
so now you see the arrows are flipped
they these two things cause the Collider
um
if you control for that collider you
will bias any association between
smoking and lung cancer
and this is a reason why if you're doing
causal inference it's actually a really
bad idea to throw a bunch of variables
into a model without actually like
thinking through the domain like sort of
domain reasons for why they're there
um so in this example again like think
of smoking as an intervention or
something you want to act on like we
could reduce smoking in a population or
have some tax on smoking and lung cancer
is the outcome
um both smoking and lung cancer cause
a large number of sick days to be taken
in populations right because if you
smoke you you know it causes like health
problems immediate health problems
sometimes
um and lung cancer will uh necessarily
result in like number of sick days being
taken being higher and so if you have a
data set with smoking and lung cancer
and number of sick days taken you would
never want to control for that collider
that red thing on the top
um that would that would induce collider
bias which um could either be positive
or negative in Direction but it's it's
going to essentially hurt your
relationship of Interest
the assessment of it
um third thing that again you don't want
to touch just be aware that it exists
and kind of recognize it identify it in
your data is something known as a
mediator
a mediator is
so again you have a treatment you have
an outcome a mediator
sits in between them one causes the
other which leads to the other
so what do you think would happen if we
killed the mediator and this if we
somehow found a way to control for it
and let's say there really isn't a a
causal relationship between treatment
and outcome and I take out that pathway
in the middle
I I think it would result in US
estimating no association or or causal
relationship between the two right
because I've taken out the pathway
um that's what happens if you control
for a mediator it'll completely nullify
any causal relationship between
treatment and outcome so
um if I were to have some sort of uh
data set that had smoking lung cancer
down the line and clinical signs of lung
damage like sort of pre-cancerous signs
of lung damage if I control for that in
my model it's going to result in me uh
misunderstanding the causal relationship
between smoking and lung cancer
so in this case I know that's a mediator
so I'm not going to touch that I'm not
going to control for that you want to
always control for confounders don't
control for mediators or colliders and
those are the three relationships really
um I presented really idealized examples
of these but in reality it reality is
really complicated it looks like this
um so I guess I would say be brave take
the variables you think are most
important from a causal perspective like
when you get a data set and just use
domain knowledge and try to understand
like how could this cause this in theory
or like what what do these relationships
look like and bring in domain experts
uh yeah so this is usually when we do
the notebook exercises but maybe I can
just sort of scroll through it
um and you know down the road you know
after the session if you're interested
you can
uh play with it yourself
is this is that clear is that a good
font size in the back yeah
yeah for sure yeah
you had economic disadvantage
oh yeah being a
causal Factor
and I was wondering if it's not a
collider or mediator
it could be
um in this situation we would want to
whiteboard it basically like you and I
would talk through what are the reasons
why you think it's a collider
um maybe this graph here is mispecified
it totally could be
um and we could definitely have a
conversation about that
um we want to bring in research domain
experts and just sort of talk through it
probably yeah yeah
yeah way to learn causal facts from
yes yes
this is maybe a controversial point but
I I try to avoid it at all costs
honestly it's um if it were like a
genuine uncertainty
say in this example and you couldn't
yeah you couldn't pump for some
agreement
yeah yeah so it's called structure
learning
um you take an observational data set
well it doesn't have to it could be the
results of like an experiment too but
you take some data set and it tries to
learn the arrows in the direction of the
arrows applying basic rules you know if
if two rows are pointing this way and I
control for this this thing vanishes
what does that tell me about the arrows
um it's a really hard problem it is
um in terms of like computation and
memory it's super exponential it is
worse than exponential
um and uh I found like there are 10
algorithms for it and I'll do I'll apply
all 10 to a data set and get completely
different results each time so I don't
know I don't know how to interpret that
and I I wonder if it's the case that if
even if you did that you're sort of
including the holes in front of the card
in front of the horse because then if
you want to then yeah use your tag to
yeah Empower like what you can tell from
your data like your data's already said
what the tag is
yeah I guess it kind of is nice though
that's an interesting point yeah it's
kind of it's almost like circular in a
way like using the data to make the dag
to inform with how the data works or
something yeah I hear you
um yeah I don't know I know some folks
that that do use structure learning they
just their approach is
learn a structure from the data
take a closer look at it once it's been
learned and sort of pick out
associations you know for sure are BS
and then sort of like fine-tune it with
your domain knowledge so I guess people
do that it's just I uh it troubles me I
guess personally but just a personal
problem Maybe
yeah
okay
uh yeah just wondering if there's a way
to
design experiments in like a
technological setup to learn a causal
tag if you don't know it a priority yes
yeah there are definitely approaches for
that I I haven't used them
um but there's definitely I've read
papers in the last few years where
they'll recommend interventions at just
the right point to kind of elucidate the
structure at this part here which is a
little bit unknown it's like targeted
intervention work I just don't know much
about that stuff but it exists yeah it's
probably really helpful yeah
um
okay is this is the text big enough here
a little bigger okay how about let me
I wish I could like
all right dumb question how do I hide
this side menu is there a way to like
oh
okay
uh okay cool so the point of this
notebook was to
um basically engineer some data to
represent those three different
relationships we just look at and so you
can kind of play with it yourself
um so the first one I'm looking at the
teacher version but you know feel free
to play around with the um you know the
attendee version too
is um classic confounding
so I took smoking coffee and lung cancer
um and
you know it allows you to essentially
um you know structure this relationship
it looks exactly like this
um wait sorry
it's this sort of relationship here
where we're considering coffee as being
an intervention like or our ability to
act on that maybe we could restrict
coffee consumption it would help lung
cancer Maybe
uh but we have the smoking confounder
and we have to control for it somehow
um
you know so we use this uh package that
allows you to specify the graph
and then Generate random samples that
fit into that graph or use that graph in
the data generating process
and so we come up with a data set where
you know for certain convenience reasons
coffee is a continuous variable and lung
cancer is also continuous it is there's
just a sort of a convenience reason for
that you'll see in a second and smoking
is binary
so we want to calculate just basic
statistical correlations here Pearson
correlations right between variables I
see that coffee and lung cancer the
Pearson relationship between these is
actually pretty it's moderate moderately
strong maybe 0.5
um
moderately strong correlation there
actually that ranges between negative
one and positive one
so moderately strong positive
correlation between coffee and lung
cancer that doesn't seem right
um so I should be skeptical if I get
this observational data set and say well
I also have smoking I know smoking is a
known confounder
um and so
essentially I'll just scroll down here
if I restrict the data set so it's only
among non-smokers I take out the
variability of smoking I can I condition
on that
um
what happens is I now find that there is
no relationship at all between coffee
and lung cancer you know so I've
controlled for the confounder
the confounder was inducing a positive
relationship between coffee and lung
cancer I control for the confounder now
I find there's nothing between coffee
and lung cancer which is expected you
know I wouldn't think there'd be any
causal or relationship between these in
reality so
um that's what it is basically in this
notebook you go over a Collide or two we
do the same basic thing
um
in this example it's
what is it a mother's genetic risk of
diabetes household income in your
childhood and a mother's diabetes
um so the idea being here you know
um mother's genetic risk of diabetes and
household income both cause mother's
diabetes risk
you know if you have a high genetic
propensity for diabetes you're causally
you know expected to have diabetes
if you grew up in a low-income
neighborhood or socioeconomic
environment it's well known that there's
a causal relationship to onset of
diabetes there too it's just a classic
epidemiology
so we have this mediator relationship
that looks sort of like this
with like two things causing the
Collider
remember I don't ever want to control
for the collider we're going to see what
happens when I do
initially I find you know I get my
observational data set there is a you
know essentially no relationship between
mom's genetic risk of diabetes and
household income
you know in this case here I find no
relationship between these two things
if I control for the collider by
doing this I now find there's like a
weak correlation there that shouldn't
exist so I've just induced bias by
collider bias
and then finally this mediation example
is identical to this here so smoking
causes
Clinic uh sort of sub pre-cancerous
clinical damage in the lungs which in
turn causes lung cancer
um is there a correlation between those
outside too the smoking and lung cancer
let's see
I generate my data set yeah there's a
moderately strong one which makes sense
right smoking lung cancer
everything that gym teachers told you
for all those years I
um I control for the mediator I control
for this middle piece here I hold it
constant
I break this pathway between these two
things and now there is no association
between smoking and lung cancer at all
which is not great
um
any questions about that I know it's
kind of hard to like scroll through
notebooks you sort of play with them to
understand what's going on with them but
high level does that make sense what
we're doing here
okay
cool
um
all right cool so yeah again repeated
this a bunch of times but you want to
control for confounders you don't want
to control for mediators and
and colliders
super controversial Point here actually
let me magnify this
um but one that I stand by uh we're
always taught that um
when you're doing machine learning
uh uh use variable importance metrics to
understand what's going on with your
model
um it's interpretable and it will give
you a sense of what's going on in the
sort of Real World Behind the model you
can tell a story from it
that is actually not correct
um
I I would argue that
you know shop
uh you know
permutation importance all these things
we use to sort of understand the
importance of variables and models only
tell you about their contribution to the
predict the predictions of the model and
how you know how useful they are so you
know we can get in a situation where you
have this result and you could say cool
um you know maybe I'm looking at 150
features here but only these are useful
I'm not going to use the rest because it
simplifies my Pipeline and makes my life
easier like that's a that's a use case
for variable importance metrics right
but um they didn't in no way tell you
you know okay the title is this high so
it's causally really important to
predicting something it doesn't tell you
the actual causal story between around
things you know using the example for
before of ice cream and violent crime in
the City ice cream would be super high
importance in this chart here if you
threw it into a model which is you know
that doesn't tell you anything causally
honestly so
um yeah so to determine causality you
need a combination of domain knowledge
and causal inference methods that's the
only way you can really get at it so
just yeah keep that in mind um I think
these plots and methods are super
important just not for
yeah go ahead
go ahead so if surname is a Collider
in addition for it so you can take you
know you take things you say I'm going
to get rid of
a surname
oh surname length okay or let's say
random or anything else that's provider
than I devising my model then
yeah you wouldn't want to include these
things in a model for sure
uh well if I guess you're not taking out
all the all the roads you just taken out
but just
so if you if you control for the
collider in your model it's um it's
going to result in like a spurious
relationship between your treatment and
outcome so
yeah you'd want to keep it out yeah
um ideally like okay I guess this isn't
really supposed to represent like a
causal model per se but just sort of a
general ml sort of approach to things
like I use a random forest model uh an
sklearn I can really easily get the
variable importance and you get
something like this I'm just saying that
um the practice of reading this and and
being able to tell people a story about
what causes what is is not a good one I
would argue yeah that's all but as far
as causality yeah
the income to diabetes
there's there's a possibility that
there's a confounder in between those
two that you just don't know yeah that
is absolutely right yeah
um
yeah oftentimes when you're kind of
whiteboarding this and drawing out their
relationships
um you'll find that okay I've drawn a
line between this and this but there's
actually a whole bunch of things going
on there and hopefully you have data on
those things so you can sort of control
for them and model on them
um if you don't then
yeah things get a little tricky and you
have to sort of you know do deeper
digging into whether or not your problem
is solvable with what you have or you
know maybe you need another solution or
something like that
um so it's a big problem yeah
um for sure
okay uh
does everyone have the slides open right
now
or is it okay this is I don't know like
a group activity I guess but there are
four um big assumptions to causal
imprints I mean it's not magic it's not
there's no free lunch
um it's a useful thing and it will help
you determine causality but certain
conditions have to be met
um the first of which is
um you know causes always occur before
effects that's you know just basic
um that's how the world works and so
whatever treatment variable you're
considering
um
you know in the case of the New York
Times talk from the first day that would
be sort of you know how do we ratchet
this thing left and right that's the
intervention we can do
um your data I mean the way you sort of
have your data set constructed that has
to have occurred before the outcome
um if that makes sense you know if it's
flipped around then you're not really
telling a true console story from this
it's it's something else it's just um I
don't know what it would be
um there's something called the stable
unit treatment value assumption which is
just you know you can simplify that
suggests the treatment of an individual
doesn't affect the outcomes of other
individuals so in cases when you're
doing like social media causal type
associations it gets really tricky here
um unless you know you can actually
verify that these things are isolated
and sort of you know not affecting the
outcomes of others
uh positivity is a way of saying
essentially you have enough data so that
within each sort of substrata of uh
confounders you're controlling for you
have enough data there you know so if I
only have like 100 observations and I
want to control for like 50 confounding
variables uh you're going to violate
that assumption big time I mean there's
there won't be enough variability there
for the model to learn what's going on
within each of like the sort of
substrata of confounders
um and that ignorability which is
probably the biggest one that you just
raise that actually in the back which is
um you have to account for all major
confounding variables and if you don't
do that it's unfortunate but your
results will not be trustworthy I mean
usually that's the one that will sink
you in practice just you know you don't
have what you need to control for things
unfortunately
um okay so if you can keep that slide
open
um
you can use it for this next few slides
here so example one I'm wondering if you
could try to guess or just say out loud
what violation is being is occurring
here of these assumptions it can be one
two three or four of the assumptions or
or whatever or any combination
um I want to understand whether frequent
emails to customers might impact
customer satisfaction
that makes sense I have survey data with
customer self-reported satisfaction from
a year ago
and I use this past models uh this past
month's number of emails for each
customer as a proxy for how often we
email them generally so
yeah what was that
temporality exactly okay so I have
um I've switched around the sort of
ordering the temporal ordering of these
things the cause has to occur before
wait sorry the effect the cost has to go
before the effect right
um okay example two
I want to see the causal impact of a
neighborhood's cleanliness on crime
rates
um controlling for 20 known confounders
I pull up an academic data set with data
on 40 unique neighborhoods or districts
and the unit of analysis in my analysis
is a neighborhood so I essentially have
40 rows of data
I want to control for 20 confounders
so it's like 40 rows 20 columns
what do you think
positive yeah positivity yeah
um there's no way I can have enough
variability of treatment and outcome
with that few observations and that many
columns it's just you know there's going
to be a lot of sparsity sort of in the
different
combinations of confounding variables
there
um okay third one I I want to see how
releasing a new in-app multiplayer game
through my social media app and packs
user engagement
um I only want to give it to some test
users initially
uh with this multiplayer game you can
play with anyone on the app
um and in this situation uh oh uh it
turns out test users can invite non-test
users in to play too
so
what do you think about that
yeah exactly exactly
um second one here
and then finally we're curious how a job
training program can impact a person's
income three years in the future
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
data on the participants so we're only
really going to control for age in this
analysis so it's just you know was I in
this program yes or no age and income in
the future
what do you what do you think
maybe I don't have enough variables
there to control for there's a lot going
on so
um
ignorability yeah yeah
um so you would you would be advised in
this case not to do causal inference
analysis on this just you know
um I don't know
okay uh how are we doing for time
okay uh
so I want to get practical now this is
stuff that you can actually walk away
with and start using immediately as long
as you sort of think through is it you
know is it usable in this case there's a
technique called s learning or G
computation depends what domain you're
in epidemiology we call it g computation
econometricians call it s learning
um if you're an industry you can call it
whatever you want I guess
um the way it works is it's a way of
using a model to control for confounding
variables to assess the impact of a
treatment on an outcome
so this is a really useful thing this
will answer the question of I have some
intervention and I want to see what it
does on my outcome controlling for a
bunch of things that are sort of
nuisance variables confounders right so
it's very simple too it's very easy and
quick you can implement it within like
10 to 20 lines of code it's great uh
so let's say you have a data set like
this a very typical data frame you have
some set of covariates that we know are
likely confounders through our domain
knowledge and sort of understanding of
the field I have some treatment that's
binary and I have some outcome
and the way it works is
I train a model you can any sort of
model will work something from sklearn
could be as simple as logistic
regression it doesn't really matter or
regression in this case I train a model
to predict the outcome from all the
covariates and the treatment
so I take cover one kovar 2 and
treatment as my predictors and I predict
the outcome pretty simple so far right
I then have this trained model and what
I do is
I'm going to run the data that I trained
through that model to get the
predictions but before I do that I'm
going to force everyone in the data set
to receive treatment so before some
people didn't some people did you know
um
you know in the The New York Times talk
and the first day here you know some
people
um you know through through like prior
experiments and such some people got a
number of Articles they were able to
read
um like you know 50 20 and some people
only got five there's some variability
there
um but what I do here is I force
everyone to receive the treatment
um so in some cases this is the
counterfactual right like the IDS three
and four these people actually didn't
get the treatment in real life
but I'm exploring the counter factual
there so I force everyone to get the
treatment
and I I get the predictions
these are the predictions
right from the model
um
I then Force everyone to not receive
treatment and I run it through the model
again and I collect the outcome from
that and so I don't know why these last
two column names aren't showing up but
that's supposed to be
um
with treatment outcome and this is
supposed to be without treatment outcome
and then what I do is I simply calculate
the difference between those two
predicted columns
and I average the effect
across the whole data set if that makes
sense
did that make sense did I skip over
something didn't okay so it makes sense
right
um and what this is this 3.1 is
essentially
um the conditional average treatment
effect of that treatment on the outcome
controlling for those two covariates
which are confounders
and that's really all you have to do
um you can
um
there's a number of ways you can look at
this you can do this in the overall
population the entire data set and
that's called the um
conditional average treatment effect if
you want to look at just the people that
actually receive treatment in real life
that's the conditional
um average treatment effect among the
treated
and you can look at any sub segment you
want to you can even get individual
treatment effects I can say what's the
effect for individual one it was four
which is really cool I can guess you
know like your particular the impact of
the treatment on just you controlling
for these attributes that you have
um so that's a powerful thing and
relatively simple to
um again so
definitely encourage you
um on your own time to kind of take a
look at
uh let me
pull this up
this notebook which goes into G
computation or S learning
um if
in case you want to know this is
implemented in causal ml the python
package so we just you can go right to
that if you want to use it out of the
box it's it's there it's easy to use
Simple API but it's also really simple
to to do this yourself so in this case
here
uh there's a classic
um kind of canonical causal inference
data set called the LA landi dataset or
the lawn data set I'm not sure
and it is a job training program type
data set so you have some attributes of
people some socioeconomic covariates
that we want to control for
you have
um
earnings I believe this is the outcome
variable in this data set typically and
then there's an indicator variable here
one or zero for whether or not they were
part of this job training program we
want to see if that has an impact on
income in the future
so data set looks like this
you know I can do some some basic
manipulation here some scaling and such
um
using sklearn I fit a very simple linear
regression model
which I think most people are probably
familiar with that API for that
and yeah and then we do what I mentioned
before which is essentially you know
copy your data set and then now Force
everyone to receive the treatment so now
and this data set here everyone is a one
in this column
um you know by sheer luck here in these
these five observations here everyone
was a one but there are some zeros here
too
um so I do that I get the predictions
from the model I get the mean prediction
the mean outcome predicted is this in
terms of you know dollars
and now I force everyone to not receive
the
um the treatment not to have attended
the the program make the predictions and
I get this number here and this Delta
between this and this is your treatment
effect
which is this so we can say controlling
for those covariates that we showed you
earlier the treatment effect is
estimated to be a little under 17
000 dollars
yes yeah
um that that estimate can change for
sure yeah I mean the the best guidance I
I've sort of gathered from people is
you want your trained model to be as
balanced and accurate as possible
and so you know it's I don't think
there's a problem with going with like
boosted trees or whatever you know or
something or gradient boosting or
something yeah
um
yeah but it will change if we try to
different models here model here it
might be slightly different
um
it kind of you opened a whole can of
worms actually I mean we can sort of
like do this a number of ways but you
get into an issue of like multiple
testing you know so there are ways to
get P values associated with this and
like significance and if I were to try a
bunch of different things and sort of
you know some are positive or
significant some are not
there are issues with that so I
typically just
early on in the process try to train a
model which is fairly predictive fairly
balanced and stick with it
but yeah you can yeah
oh interesting um
so I mean we did a lot of that like in
epidemiology and iconometrics
um you know so they use a lot of like
linear models and things because you
know you can get those coefficients and
they have actual meaning
um so people do that uh in the case you
know I tend to use like gradient
boosting these days for this sort of
problem and it's it's I don't think you
can in that case really but but yeah
people take linear models all the time
and interpret that causally yeah
thanks assuming it's specified the right
way the model yeah yeah
I can try repeating it for you too
so some of the some of those variables
could be colliders that you're
conditioning for they could be so but
you're just taking them all in in
essence you're Cur you're in this
controller here you're conditioning for
everything that's not that you're not
modifying yeah in this scenario here
let's say I've thought about it already
and I've sort of whiteboarded this with
people and my understanding of these is
that are that they are confounders not
colliders if they were if we did sort of
say you know what I think this
particular variable is probably a
collider or maybe we're unsure
um you wouldn't want to include it yeah
then in the example you use the linear
regression yeah so in that case
if you looked at the coefficient of the
treatment effect
you would get the same result I think
than this approach or this is true
that's true yeah
um
the only Advantage I would say to this
sort of approach is that you can use
really powerful machine learning and you
know in theory you could
I guess I don't know why you would but
it's tabular data you could use a deep
learning model to like power your G
computation and
um higher predict you know higher
predictive performance is a good thing
in this case like it will result in
better estimation of the treatment
effect but yeah if it's a linear model
for sure you could just look at the
coefficient of that treatment variable
and that's going to sort of have
controlled for the other things yeah
and um compared to other methods like
premises score matching or
how would the G Factor compare yeah
um there is a really good paper out it's
in nature and I think they compare
propensity propensity score matching is
another approach for doing this
essentially it Compares this
to that to another approach under
different conditions and it depends a
bit yeah there are certain conditions
when one is better than the other but I
think
I think if you're getting started this
is a decent one to get started with and
it's easy to understand and you can sort
of you know you people are familiar with
the sklearn API so they can jump into it
um but if you're interested in this
stuff definitely explore propensity
score matching too it's a it's another
way of doing it
um essentially you match I mean in
theory you would match individuals that
received and didn't receive treatment to
each other based on how similar they are
um so yeah it's it's another approach
too
thank you yeah
okay
um
see here so we went over that I'm almost
done I think uh
but yeah so um for those that are
interested you might say well what if
your treatment variable is not binary I
mean up to this point it's only been one
or zero
um and there are ways for doing that too
you know um maybe you want to model
price or waiting time or how much leads
you know how many micrograms of lead or
something is in your blood
um
and so
you know you might you might get a data
set like this like there are different
levels of treatment values here in our
observational data right and different
outcome uh values associated with them
and so you know traditionally when we
see a plot like this we just we draw a
line through it right like a line of
best fit or are we you know apply some
approach to like kind of make that line
smoother
um but the way we think of this in terms
of like causal estimation is different
um what's going on here is actually kind
of a missing data problem in a sense uh
each of these points you know that top
point there that whole path that started
like that of dotted lines that
represents the sort of person's
individual
true uh
how do I put this like
um effect you would see or like outcome
you would see if they were receive that
treatment at that point you know so at
this point here
um I mean we've observed that for this
individual if this is an individual at
this treatment value effect they have
this outcome in an alternative Universe
like the universe we can't access if
they had this level of treatment we
would see this happen so this is all
missing data the dots represent the data
we know
and so
generating a causal curve is a way of
sort of estimating that true
hypothetical causal relationship so it's
different than this one right this is
the the curve that fits with the points
we see
what we really want to estimate if we
have a continuous treatment variable is
this actually this is sort of the
underlying true one that we can't
observe
um I mean most of these points here are
counterfactuals right because we didn't
see it's all missing data or data we
don't have um and so that's what you
want to do with this approach yeah
I I don't know I just made it up yeah oh
okay oh yeah yeah it's um yeah I didn't
have anything in mind I just wanted to
kind of like show like oh it could be
some you know crazy effect it sometimes
happens I mean um you know yeah yeah
what's that
yeah maybe maybe there's some sort of
non-linear effect that um yeah or or
some plateauing effect or something like
that but um it'll appear different than
this What You observe only yeah
so
um
I'll skip that it's you know on your own
time definitely
um
check out this
you know
this notebook here it goes into
how to generate causal curves
um you can look into
these libraries out there that do this
for you and sort of the theory behind it
I don't want to like overwhelm folks
with a theory at this point but it's you
know it's definitely very doable in this
notebook here
we take a really large public data set
the unhanes data set it's put out by the
CDC it's a great data set tens of
thousands of people in it
um and yeah we have all these sort of
let's say there let's assume it for the
purposes of this exercise they're all
known confounders
but we definitely want to have that
conversation and think through that if
it's a data set that we we don't know
very well
um and the treatment of Interest here is
uh lead in your blood we want to see if
there's some causal effect to decreasing
lead in your blood whether that relates
to
cognitive scores in children so if a
child has less lead in their blood do
they perform better on math reading
block and digits tests I think block and
digit are like memory and
spatial awareness test or something like
that so it's an important question I
mean there's a lot of like lead exposure
even in you know New York City in some
neighborhoods and um if we were to enact
some policy to change that and sort of
shift the Curve that might have a really
great effect on the city and sort of
educational outcomes which is awesome
um and so that's what you explore here
in this notebook essentially
you know you get this data set you look
at the distribution of blood lead it
looks like this in this population of
children
um you know so it's skewed as you might
expect here the distribution of
scale test scores so here's the math
scores reading block test digit test
and now we want to do causal inference
to see if there's a causal relationship
and what that relationship looks like
between lead exposure and these test
results and so
you implement
um
you use this package called causal curve
to do that
um
and uh
where is it here
there we go okay these are the console
curves so what these represent in this
case here
let's take reading for example
um
dark line is the line that's estimated
this is the 95 confidence interval so
what it's saying is if
we had a population of children with you
know and then the x-axis here represents
blood lead
that we're at four is it micrograms per
DL
four units of lead exposure
and we you know reduced it to two
this Delta here is what you'd expect to
see causally in terms of an improvement
in test scores so like that whatever the
Delta is between here and here it goes
up slightly
that's the estimated impact it's kind of
nice in a way because you can sort of
visualize this thing and see any
non-linearities and see what that causal
curve looks like if you have continuous
treatment variables to work with at
least so
um yeah it's it's a pretty powerful
thing
um and uh
I'm gonna shamelessly plug this this is
so I put this package together this is
my sort of covid project in 2020.
um there's also this option here of
understanding
mediation effects so
to put it to you this way
um uh people have sort of proposed that
the relationship between lead exposure
and bad educational outcomes is partly
mediated by income
uh income and um uh sort of lower SES or
socioeconomic status and so what you can
do here is
answer that question in essence you can
say
you know as I sort of alter
the level of poverty in this data set
you know what proportion of this
relationship between sort of positive
relationship between lead exposure and
test scores
yeah is mediated by this income and you
see actually it's it's not trivial it's
about 20 of it so
kind of an interesting outcome there to
explore
um
so yeah I think we're almost done a few
slides left uh and so I would suggest uh
if you're leaving this confused I'm
sorry I can talk to you after the talk I
hope to resolve that but here's a simple
sort of flow chart to help you on your
early steps on causal inference you know
so if you have a treatment variable that
is binary nominal
um
uh or no perhaps I recommend going down
the left side of this flowchart here
do employ G computation or S learning
to to do that that was the second
notebook we looked at
if you have a continuous
um treatment variable I'd recommend
going down the right path here use the
causal curve package
to do that and depending on what your
outcome is that you're trying to sort of
work with continuous or binary these
these four
nodes on the bottom tell you which
models to use or what how to approach
that so
um so yeah I guess like just parting
suggestions
um again like make sure you have a
pretty healthy amount of domain
knowledge before you do this work
definitely not something you want to
just throw numbers in yep
our work in Industry yeah
I'm just in my world the main knowledge
almost certainly would increase
domain knowledge would almost certainly
what's up introduce bias oh interesting
uh what industry are you in I'm just
curious
collect a lot of sensory data oh wow
interesting
yeah
thank you we did a question we might
answer is uh well does
um
does does the machine that a person runs
does the machine a person run sorry does
the person running a machine impact this
the speed of the process and the the
domain knowledge would be say the the
management of that facility yeah whom
would almost certainly tell you yes it
does but it's in it's it's an intuition
it's I it's again I'm kind of struggling
with how you define domain knowledge
because again in my world that that's
it's that can be very tricky
tell me if I'm off base here is it is
this almost a case of like bad domain
knowledge like the the knowledge you're
getting about this domain is like bad or
like you know I I could well or like
it's it's highly biased that if I see
somebody working very hard I assume that
person's productive that's biased yeah
that's not it yeah
that's um that's tricky
I
for saying I don't know how hopefully
you would have access to some sort of
trustworthy understanding of some
process that's going on it's hard I mean
in Academia at least when I did this
stuff
you know they're just reams of Journal
articles out there to rely on you can
sort of construct the dag from what
you've learned from articles you know I
think this is causing this and that's
causing that I guess it gets trickier in
some industry scenarios where yeah like
you said it
I don't know I don't have an easy answer
for that yeah
that's an interesting one I'll have to
think about that
in a sense we we try to introduce a
domain knowledge or
it to deploy the domain knowledge
ourselves trying to be as as data driven
as we can
um yeah that on the other hand we kind
of run up against the boundary of our
own domain knowledge and it's really
trying to fit in the Gap and I was just
curious because again you've mentioned
it several times and yeah thank you
that's that's a tricky one yeah thanks
I'll have to think about that
yeah
um yeah so just some suggestions here
um
one thing to keep in mind is with these
approaches you can definitely calculate
p-values and statistical significance
but do you want to avoid scenarios where
you sort of game the thing and test it
multiple times in different subsets like
you will definitely you know if you're
looking for a good story and you try
different subsets you will definitely
find a good story but it may not be the
true one
um I I know some buddies in the data
science Industry that work
under sales teams which seems really
tough
um and and they're in these situations
quite a bit so yeah it's it's tough
um
and that I love this article uh by um
the the smart folks at Stitch fix
um
they uh wrote some things about like you
know roughly estimating how much of the
time business ideas are actually work
out or you know are true or work out
um and most business or research ideas
will fail unfortunately so uh you know
um definitely approach your results with
some skepticism but try to be open to
the fact that maybe what everyone
considers to be a brilliant idea doesn't
work for some reason or another so
um
that is it yeah any questions
thanks for the talk again
um so I know you might mentioned about
multiple testing and yeah there are
often times we want to measure the
effectiveness of treatment group within
subgroups like you know yeah whether it
worked for a particular state or so I
was wondering in that those cases do we
have that variable as a covariate in the
model that we are building to like for
the conditional average treatment effect
or do we just train two different models
for each of the subgroups and oh
interesting yes
um
I don't know if they're I mean I I guess
the approach I would take is I would
train one overall model and then use
that to explore sub-populations
um
uh
but definitely if I'm testing a lot of
different sub populations and I'm
calculating p-values from these things I
I try to account for that there's a
number of Corrections you can do to sort
of
prevent
um false positives so yeah thank you
yeah sure
so I was hoping that there would be a
statistical test that would
differentiate between correlation and
causality
uh what I what I my take away from this
is that maybe there's not right so yeah
the ice cream example you gave at the
beginning about summer and whatever is
also used I think in textbooks for
hidden Markov chains yep right that
there's hidden uh things that so I mean
my takeaway from this is you really have
to apply domain knowledge and even then
there may be things you're not observing
or not thinking about
that can make correlation appear causal
yeah yeah
um I for my money this is much harder
than classic ML and and predictions I
mean in that case you know I have a
training set I have a test set
I um I can toss stuff in and I can prove
over time that it's predicting well
um and I can you know sleep well at
night basically but with this it's
there's like a bit of art involved
there's a bit of like possibly
questionable domain knowledge as this
gentleman suggested
um and uh yeah it's a little fuzzy
I don't know I guess that's sort of the
sac that's what you have to pay for sort
of trying to get at a causal claim that
you can't do with an experiment you know
yeah yeah
sorry though well thank you that's a
good takeaway yeah wondering about this
for a long time yeah yeah that would be
great so it was yeah but I'm hearing is
there really is no weeks
yeah
Davis yeah I think I think the folks
that um that
the proponents of uh structure learning
like the folks that you know there's a
group of folks out there that are like
we have data sets and we could through
sheer computation we can try to figure
this out
and I can try to sort of really
understand causality I I they may have a
different take on that but it you know
for me it's that's not the case yeah
it's just it's thinking through what's
going on and then combining that with
empirical you know analysis yeah because
just taking this right yeah I could I
could think of my thesis that
socioeconomic disadvantage
leads to high ER lung cancer
yeah but I might have missed one of
these other bubbles yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um
uh in epidemiology
um there have probably been like
like 300 plus Papers written on the
relationships between socioeconomic
status
depression and
metabolic disorders
and um it's like only after those 300
papers there's a review article which
says we think it looks like this you
know like these are the structures this
is really hard you know I don't know so
you just take your best stab at it and
invite a lot of people and whiteboard it
you know yeah
thank you yeah sure
yeah thanks for a really nice talk um I
have two questions first is in um the
case where you showed the graph of
outcome versus treatment where treatment
is continuous and then the red was kind
of away from
um the fit to the black points
um yes would that still be the case if
the treatment is randomized or are you
referring to the this particular case
when the treatment is
is observed
um yeah I I think it would work in in
your case I imagine yeah if you get data
from the results of a B test yeah
um yeah I guess
I guess though if you
um if you have like run like five prior
a b tests and you have sort of like you
know here's here's treatment value one
two three maybe then this wouldn't be
the right approach because you could you
could make that binary or sort of you
know you could handle that without a
this sort of setting you know
yeah and uh one more question also
related to the correlation with this
causation comment
um from your perspective do you think
that randomization is like still the
gold standard for distinguishing
correlation and causation so if you see
two variables correlated you run a
randomized control trial yeah that is
what answers causation uh I think it's
the best tool we have it um by
randomizing
treatment you you essentially break all
confounding Because treatment status
there's no way it can be caused a sort
of associated with any possible
confounder all right because it's random
so yeah
so it's the best thing I know of I don't
know thank you yeah
yeah
sorry I'm is there anything special to
say if you're working in a Bayesian
framework is it is it basically the same
you just do your G computation you get
your posterior predictive basically or
anything yeah different or special
uh I guess not I mean
yeah probably not you could code it up
very similar I imagine and you just
encode it in whatever priors you have I
guess and just let it roll yeah
um yeah I know someone that implemented
G computation with um Pi MC3 a few
months ago
and they got a nice distribution at the
end of like the treatment effect is like
you know whatever yeah so and uh what
was what was the results about the
vitamin D and covet did that I forget if
you actually said but oh sorry the
vitamin D and covid
uh I don't even know actually I'm kind
of curious Let's uh
yeah
classic epidemiology yeah interesting
okay
uh you would mention
you mentioned uh well
oh is that one not working here better
okay there we go uh you had mentioned
that there are strategies for kind of
testing for mediation and I remember
like 15 years ago in the behavioral
sciences there was this whole series of
progressions you'd run and subtract
coefficients from each other what's the
current thinking on those strategies
so there is a test for mediation that
was proposed a long time ago
um and uh I think I might have even used
that in grad school early on I I'm
hoping we've gotten better yeah yeah I
know so my understanding was
um it was really crude like you
essentially
uh get a correlation get a correlation
not controlling for the mediator and
then get a correlation controlling for
it and then it looks at that Delta and
determines whether it's significant and
that's like I guess that proves
mediation I guess
um yeah I have anything better I don't
know anything better really
um
yeah I'm not not sure
that'd be really cool though if that
worked
and you could really figure a lot of
things out yeah
um I I'll just say with like mediation
and like survey data there's a lot being
done on the oh really it's ecology space
you can get a whole book and
there's a lot done on the psychology
space
it's too quick for some reason the Name
Escapes me I'll look it for you in like
30 seconds and and have it to you
um but he has he has a SAS macro he has
a state of macro and and that's all that
he does is teach mediation with called a
process variable
um is it like a test for mediation or
yeah so you can so you can test for that
variable if if it's a mediation if
there's moderated mediation and there's
like 60 odd models that you can try to
oh that's cool try to try to put through
it
um
and you know it's like any statistical
test
um
you know I think I think the problem
that I have with it is that
um you can kind of find whatever you
want
it's like yes this mediates now we can
publish so
rather than more stringent tests of
associate you know of like
um sem or more traditional things
got it
so so for G computation you just want to
make sure to take out the colliders and
the mediators out of the that can you
leave everything else in assuming that
they're confounders I mean is that going
to make a difference or
um yeah you'd want to include just the
confounders oh you don't so something
that's just neutral you don't want to I
mean I guess
one second let me pull this up here
so I guess like what you're talking
about is something like this maybe
there was a
good uh
okay so like this one here is completely
unrelated to everything else
but it does happen to to relate to lung
cancer are you sort of asking like if I
include this in the model will it throw
anything off I mean or even if it wasn't
related to lung cancer at all yeah
um I guess I guess in a scenario where
you're so let's say like this is a a
very well known structure and we all
believe in it and we all trust it and it
actually is true
throwing this into the G computation
model isn't going to hurt you at all
yeah
but but if it is somehow
like related to something which relates
to something else which causes bias
that's going to cause a problem but if I
know for a fact like it is an unrelated
predictor
it's causally related to the outcome a
touch is nothing else then yeah it
doesn't doesn't hurt to throw it in yeah
um this is a little bit similar to the
first question but I was wondering how
often do two people analyzing the same
data get get different results maybe
because due to the
um the understanding that they have yeah
um
it can definitely happen I'll say that
much
um
I think the trick is to just you know if
you're if you and your organization are
really going to commit to doing
something like this like you you can't
run an A B test but you really want to
get as close as you can to that you have
to just you know gather all the
stakeholders together figure out the
best structure you can and then
test it as few times as possible because
you can gain it you know you can sort of
find things that you want to find yeah
thank you yeah
any more questions everybody
okay thank you all very much
[Applause]